j'ai voulu être la première femme à
réaliser un tour du monde en solitaire
parce que dans le domaine de la voile
les hommes ont pratiquement tout fait
cette femme est entrée dans l'histoire
christine h lorsque alice qui évite ch
polonaise boucler un périple de deux ans
sur son voilier les femmes elles
n'avaient encore jamais fait de telles
choses
j'ai donc voulu être la première à le
faire cette année là tout changer mais
il faudra attendre 1991 soit très années
plus tard pour voir une femme faire un
tour du monde en solitaire mais dans le
cadre d'une course au large
elle est française et s'appelle isabelle
autissier un pied de nez à tous ceux qui
pensaient que le tour du monde à la
voile
c'était une affaire d'hommes il va
falloir que les hommes les vrais les
tatoués se fassent une raison il faut
définitivement compter avec la mort ce
sont de grands marins ou marine peu
importe comment cela se dit elle
terminera septième de cette compétition
le boc challenge est plus dur pour une
femme que pour un homme
elle répond calmement ce qui est très
important c'est la tactique de course y
la réflexion compte plus finalement que
la force physique pure bon il faut pas
négliger mais qui n'est plus le facteur
principal que donc les femmes ont toutes
leurs chances en s'aliénant ces courses
là pourquoi pas un jour de gagné autre
femme a marqué la mère de son empreinte
catherine chabaud en 1996 elle
participer au vendée globe
une autre course autour du monde mais
sans escale cette fois et elle est la
première femme à réaliser un tel exploit
alors avant de partir on lui pose la
traditionnelle question sur son sexe
mais elle s'en fiche
j'y pense pas à tout ça c'est vrai que
tout l'entourage ne le renvoie
mais ça j'y pense pas du tout à quoi
pense-t-elle aux mers du sud
comme tout bon marin je rêve de voir des
icebergs
mais j'ai une peur bleue de jeu cache
absolument pas que j'aie la pétoche d'y
aller j'ai a fait tache d'huile dans le
sud mais bon je sais j'ai envie d'y
aller à son retour on lui offre un
bouquet de fleurs
catherine chabaud n'échappe pas à son
genre une si grosse bouteille de
champagne
c'est un peu trop pour les petits bras
musclés catherine chabaud heureusement
le public est là pour l'aider
de nombreuses navigatrice prendre la mer
dans le sillage de ces pionnières
l'anglais ellen macarthur termine 2e du
vendée globe en 2001 elle avait 24 ans
et puis il y aura and i heard est karen
leibovici samantha davies pour l'édition
2020 du vendée globe
elles sont six femmes inscrites sur la
ligne de départ encore une première
[Musique]